hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to alien isolation
we're going to be revisiting this game
because
i am currently in isolation and you can
get this game
for free through the link in the
description below on the epic game store
which this video is brought to you by
because i
am an epic games partner
it's very special i know you can also
use code markiplier on the store to
support me
if you decide to okay so there's been
some dlc about this game that i have not
played i believe this is
the one that i haven't played but i'm
not 100
sure now if you don't remember me
playing alien isolation there's a link
in the description that also goes to the
playlist to be doing it
man 2037 has some really shitty
terminals you know you'd think that
there would be a little bit more advance
like i don't know we're gonna blow up
the ship we'll take our chances in the
shuttle
good we're gonna need coolant for the
air support system
did i play this i don't think i did this
that sounded i powered up the shuttle
have you got those coolant tanks ready
oh no we're doing it you want to give us
a hand down here
that's sigourney weaver so this must be
emulating the original
alien movie i don't think i played this
before and also i've forgotten entirely
how to play
i really am a uh oh it's also very dark
oh no that was the thing that was really
enjoyable about the first game is that
it was quite
spooky you know the whole isolation
thing it really was true
like oh my god
[Applause]
[Music]
all right well what come on
come on
parker lambert
well that didn't sound too good this
doesn't seem very familiar except that
er
like i do know the movie a little bit so
i would guess that i would know
something about that but
i honestly have no idea hello
am i an alien trouble right oh i am
morning
excuse him i i thought he said hold
hold e to hide and then i let go i guess
if you hold it too long you'll pop right
out i'm assuming
i'm assuming that i'm okay for now
oh i'm not okay for now i'm oh
well maybe i will be okay whoa mama hate
it
oh mama hello
anybody down here is that blood no his
electronics
even worse okay all right oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] what what did you see what did you
see sigourney
weevie what did you see
don't just say that oh all right i got
more stuff
i don't recall there being this kind of
stuff before
do i have a map
oh that's a locker it's what is that
wait what the hell
do i have a flashlight why is it so
goddamn dark
why light work the same way in space as
it do on earth
all right i'm assuming all these weird
noises are just the ship being
you know they made they made spaceships
real noisy in the future
in the past's future anyway yeah
real squonky full of squinkaloon oh
god i hate it what is that
what is that what goes blue
all right okay nothing go blown nothing
got blown
i don't know what quad pr means
what the heck is thumper lumpin what the
heck is thumpa lumpin
uh okay i see a box of goodies
i see a box of goodies take that yeah
oh no no
no i'll get you yeah come at me [ __ ] oh
try me try me out
oh i'll mess you up every day every day
every day every way
every day i'll come i'm coming for you
yeah that's why i thought you better be
that took 22.
all right maybe maybe i'm not the
smartest dude
i'll hide later i seem to be okay
well that was extremely dumb
oh uh hey what's up i didn't expect you
to be back so soon i'm gonna go upstairs
i'm gonna go upstairs i'm gonna go
upstairs i'm going up
uppy stairsy up he's scarcity i have no
idea what i'm looking for anyway
um so you know me actually having a
chance here oh
i found the dead end
oh god no
i really i don't have a good idea what
the map is here so i really don't
understand anything that's supposed to
be happening
um oh boy scrap i found a bunch of crap
i found a bunch of shitty crap you know
scrap
really gonna help me
yep okay
so there was something about saying cool
and
oh god okay ah no dead end you're right
yeah i'm right you're right
i'm going down i'm gonna die oh i'm
going down
this is going just about as terribly as
i could have hoped
just about just about i'm just gonna oh
well it knows now it knows oh boy
oh not though
[Music]
well ain't that just peach let's try
that again
shall we so um the flamethrower doesn't
actually make it run away
i mean it seems like when i get hit it's
kind of like
kind of like thing in my brain
[Music]
oh yeah you big baby
yeah why you're gonna you're gonna hear
all that you're gonna hear parker go
and be like parker you all right
you okay parky my spoon
my spleen parker
you all right you need a cough drop you
okay all right i don't know where
oh no where what are you seeing what are
you seeing
what are you seeing that i'm not seeing
oh
parker you okay
ah your face seems to be missing
part of it oh [ __ ] i think parker's
taking a nap
uh is this hidey hole enough
i forget what
i forget what actually is like enough
holy heidi
oh this is probably
oh oh parker oh god
parker yo oh god oh god uh oh oh god oh
god oh god oh god
radio menu all right i'm ready to throw
down [ __ ]
oh i'm reloading don't come now [ __ ]
i'm not ready to throw down
okay i don't know if this is parker
hmm that's a problem all right
oh god oh oh oh my god okay all right
we're doing this
i said okay
i'm hiding oh that's not a it's not a
hidey hole it's not
the thing is what is was not oh god oh
god oh god oh god oh god
i don't know what if you do whatever i
just did please cut it the [ __ ] out
that was shockingly involuntary
what i just did anyway sorry that was
very
i was i've never experienced a reaction
before in my life anyway
it was because i'm on a laptop i can't
see anything maybe we can
brighten now i'm at max brightness you
see something it's recording right yeah
it's recording okay
i was recording a little slumpishly but
you know it's trying his best you know
slumpish though it may be
make sure it's all good who knows like
i'm on a laptop
okay why is j why are you at 90 knots
what are you
doing all right it is what it is guys
i'm on a laptop
no no no
i was gonna hold my breath
[Music]
hi uh so funny story
very funny actually um really funny
story
so uh my recording crashed is it
running smooth who knows since that
crashed i just wanted to
show you guys what you missed you know
oh eve
ms paige is lucky
i've never seen us
so i'm securing right all right okay
here's
sigourney weaver here here we go
right okay that's jordy weaver i'm going
through
and there's a box right here
that's a locker you got your slats so i
go
in the locker right so i'm in the locker
i go
in the locker right so i go in here and
i'm all
like
and so i get in there and i'm all like
i'm
in there right i'm in there
you know i'm having a good time i got my
hand out
you know i'm i'm in there so right
that's me
that's me so then you know
mr big old big ol alien monster
right comes in i'm an alien you know
he's
coming all down me with his little
gangly legs and backwards
foot whatever you know you know kind of
like yeah i mean yeah i'm an
alien where look at my weird alien dick
and you know claws like brah yeah i'm
coming to get your brand yeah
you know whatever yeah ram tiny
mouth alien look at my alien dick
it's weird huh anyway there's a prompt
right
you know it says hold
breath it says hold broath you might
have seen this before
right so when hold brorth happens
this guy goes all like what the [ __ ]
what so he's all confused but it turns
out
that uh for some reason if you hold your
breath
too long you go like i don't know what
happened you like
body slam the front of this so it's it's
just like
you bash through there your tits are
hanging out
all of a sudden he's like instead of
this he goes
freaking metal gear sound effect
and he's just he he [ __ ] just
like is also get in there
and uh you know that not healthy for um
for me so that's what happened uh that's
what happened
that you missed because this crashed um
so i'm gonna give this one more try i'm
gonna go
a thrilling experience of christianity
[Music]
this goes so good guys this goes so good
let me tell you this
this could not be going gooder than it
is right now did i mention you can get
this game for free link in the
description this video brought to you by
the epic game store
hey use creative code markiplier if you
want to support
incredible gamers like me
oh just give you the most thrilling
experience possible that is what i am
all about
we'll take our chances in the shuttle
mm-hmm
good we're gonna need coolant for the
air support system we're gonna
cool it apparently all right i'm a
novice get out of my way
is there a way to turn up the brightness
too can i can i do brightness up this
adjust gamma gamma bignate embigonate
just inbigonate it we're going to
inbigonate it look i'm a novice i can't
see
[ __ ] i powered up the shuttle oh my god
i can see
oh my god i can see look oh scrap
we're crazy
[Applause]
parker
i hope that when i die to a horrible
monstrosity
i don't go
not saying that that's like a
embarrassing way to die but it's not the
proudest you know it's it
it ain't the proudest i don't think
anyone would agree that that would be a
very proud way to go
no oh no oh no
it can't be parker and lambert
actually i don't think it was lambert
but who knows whatever
all right so i don't know if you guys
saw this but i found that and i went in
here i don't exactly know where it
crashed but not in a good place
what am i looking for okay something
loose on the ship
we just ejected his body out into space
hold the hot hold the hot
hold up my went down from my back my
back are you
that was on novice i give up you know
you know
you know you know ordinarily ordinarily
i would
be trying harder than this ordinarily
here you go guys here we go guys okay
all right here you go guys
uh just editor um what you're gonna do
is you're going to um take the footage
from the game that i just showed
kind of like cut out bits of video
and overlay it so that it would assemble
what i'm about to see
so you know i'm sigourney weaver right
sigourney weaver right here i am
sigourney weaver don't dwell on the feet
don't dwell on the feet right little
dude he's all like
bro i'm gonna get you i actually have a
gun
and uh like i
uh i freaking you know i freaking
blow down you know burm
then i got away right i got away from it
i got away so here's me
and i'm just like freaking
yeah i did it you know i did it you know
i got like bagged with money here you
know
[Music]
that's pretty uh editor make that all
match up
oh i forgot sorry i forgot the important
detail here
[Music]
anyway this video is sponsored by
epic game store be sure to click in the
link description to get alien isolation
for free
available right now everyone who's ever
partnered with me and done a sponsorship
with me
has never regretted it ever
cut change
goodbye
[Music]
you